الان ينضم الينا من باريس جيل ديفير استاذ
القانون الدولي والمحامي المعتمد لدى
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اهلا بك معنا
ماذا سيترتب على هذه الشكاوى الجنائيه
التي رفعت بحق الرئيس الاسرائيلي
ه نحن نتحدث بالفعل عن شكوى جنائيه مستنده
الى الولاي القضائيه الدوليه الموجوده في
القانون العقوبات في سويسرا وبالتالي هناك
سوابق في العام 2001 على سبيل المثال
سويسرا نظرت من ضمن هذه الولايه القضائيه
في قضيه رواندا وهناك نظر في قضيه اباده
جماعيه في ذاك الحال وبالتالي هناك تواجد
لهذا الشخص على الاراضي السويسريه وهذا
قائم بالاضافه الى ذلك يجب ذكر الجرائم
وفقا
للقانون الجنائي السويسري وخصوصا الجرائم
التي ارتكبت ضد الانسانيه والاباده
الجماعيه وبالتالي برايي يمكن تلقي هذه
الشكاوى نحن بالفعل راينا ان مكتب المدعي
العام قال انه سوف ينظر في هذه القضيه
وبالتالي اطلقت العمليه طب عندما يقول انه
سينظر بهذه الشكاوى هل هذا يعني انه سيتخذ
فعل سريع ام ان الامور ستطول لاتخاذ قرار
على الاقل لوقف الرئيس
الاسرائيلي كلا نحن نتحدث عن عمليه بطيئه
في هذه الحاله وطبعا كما هو الحال دائما
على مستوى القضاء الدول يجب اخذ بعين
الاعتبار سياده الدول ونحن لم نعتد على
الاجراءات القضائيه السريعه حتى ولو كانت
الوضعيه مختلفه في حالات مختلفه طبعا على
مستوى المحكمه محكمه العدل الدوليه ما حصل
هو بالفعل امر نادر
لان الاتفاقيه الخاصه
بالابا حددت ضروره سرعه النظر بهذه
الجرائم الحال لي كذلك الان هناك نقطه
ثانيه وهي الحصانه التي يتمتع بها الرئيس
الاسرائيلي ولكن حقيقه ان الرئيس يمارس
لمهامه هذا لا يعني ان المدعي العام لا
يمكنه ان ينظر في كيفيه ممارسته لمهامه
وان يمضي قدما في هذه القضيه وبالتالي
مكتب المدع العام سوف ينظر في هذه الشكاوى
ويمكننا ان نقول ان هناك ايضا تحقيق في
الاباده الجماعيه و طبعا الجرائم ض
الانسانيه وهو مفتوح في سويسرا سيد الجل
اذا الاشكاليه هي بالحصانه التي يتمتع بها
الرئيس الاسرائيلي باي حاله يمكن ان تسقط
عنه هذه الحصانه او تسحب
منه ان نظام الحصانه
يختلف وطبعا نظام الحصانه يجب ان يحترم
عندما نتحدث عن رئيس دوله هناك مصلحه عليا
والمصلحه العليا هي تقضي بان يسمح لرئيس
الدوله بان يطلع بمهامه وبالتالي ان نظام
الحصانه هو امر يحترم للغايه ولكن في
الوقت نفسه عندما يكون المرء رئيس الدوله
ويرتكب جرائم هي خطره بالفعل تصل الى
جريمه الاباده الجماعيه وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه وجرائم الحرب لا يحظى الرئيس
بحصانه وبالتالي تسقط الحصانه هناك حصانه
مرتبطه بالمهام الرئاسيه وبالتالي هناك
حمايه معينه ولكن في الوقت نفسه عند
الاطلاع بالمسؤوليه حتى ولو كان المرء
رئيسا للدوله هناك مسؤوليه يجب ان يطلع
بها بالنسبه الى القوانين الدوليه وعند
الانتهاء من المهام الرسميه يمكن اطلاق
العمليه وهناك سابقه
حصلت السيد بينوشيه على سبيل المثال الذي
كان محميا من قبل الحصانه كرئيس دوله ولكن
بعد انتهاء
مهامه المحاكم في لندن وفي اسبانيا لاحقته
بعد انتهاء مهامه الرسميه بعد ذلك واجه
مشاكل صحي ال اخ هذا امر مختلف ولكن
الحصانه تؤخر ولكنها لا تمنع العمليه شكرا
لك من باريس جولدير استاذ القانون الدولي
والمحامل المعتمد لدى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه